as black history month kicks off this
week
we have a fantastic story from the
philadelphia tribune
the charcoal company kingsford is
celebrating
black barbecue culture in america with a
new fellowship program called
preserve the pit take a look
so as we stoke the embers of barbecue
history
we invite the next generation of
entrepreneurs to blaze their own trail
because it's only by investing in the
future
that will preserve the past
okay now here to tell us about the
barbecue genius behind
bloodsow's barbecue the compton barbecue
stand that's gone worldwide
please welcome a fifth generation pit
master who learned a barbecue
from his great aunt it's chef kevin
bluntson
hi kevin what's up yeah how y'all doing
[Applause]
wow honored to meet you
i've been to your la outpost
and it is just i mean there's a reason
that you franchised and become
such a huge deal kevin thank you for
stopping by oh the pledge is all mine
i'm elated to meet you in all ross i'm
looking forward to this
let's have some fun today
[Laughter]
we are so honored to be speaking with
you and also
you are a mentor in this new incredible
fellowship program will you please tell
us
about preserve the pet oh wow preserve
the pit
by kingsford it's the prime example of
of somebody keeping it 100 and putting
money where their mouth
is i mean the biggest problem a lot of
times when you start a business is
not knowing the know-how and having all
the information so many restaurants
fail kingsford is putting a stop to all
that i mean they have some
legendary and not talking about myself
some legendary up-and-coming young
pit masters i mean i tell people right
now go to preserve the pit
right now and sign up uh if you got
until now until march 1st and starting
april we're going to get this thing
going and we're going to have these
people locked in
from april to september teaching them
everything
and and drew you know what's happening
you got some neighborhood in you you
know game is to be sold and not towed
and we giving it up kingsford and us is
giving up kings we've been putting good
smoke in the air
for a long long time and now they are
really
paying it forward in what they're doing
i am so proud to be part of this it's
crazy what an incredible way to learn
yeah and everybody loved i mean loves
barbecue we've been eating barbecue
around here
yeah but barbecue's in your bones kevin
you say you learned everything from your
great aunt her name willie mayfield
right you call granny yeah yes miss
granny yes miss willie may feels
question count of texas uh
and my mom learned a lot from my mom
gene blood bledsoe she have a fit if i
keep kicker out of it but uh
you know i'm born i'm born and raised in
compton so uh i had the best of both
worlds you know i had to you know grew
up in
like i said i had the uh uh the tough
streets of compton
and the country roads of texas and uh i
learned both sides and i got to work
with her every summer she had this
little hole in the wall
underground juke joint that uh had a
whole lot of things going on but i
always turn it to the uh
karate kid wax on wax off she was
teaching me
things that i never thought i would use
in my life
that i still use to this day man because
that's what she would always say
well you got to get your legal hustle
you know what i mean legal hustle me
learn how to do something because you
never know when time's going to get hard
you're gonna lose the job or something
like that and you need something legal
to fall back on
and who would have known years later you
know i would be doing blessings with the
things that you taught me
and that's what this program is about if
i didn't have people like her
in my life and teaching me and now
kingsford and preserve the pit is giving
me the opportunity to
give it back to some people who really
really need it man it's just it's
amazing
and i am so glad to be part of this
which
and some young and upcoming legends on
this team with us
it's going to be incredible man i'm
really looking forward to it i love your
food
so much i was so excited to do this with
you
thank you from me and ross really
uh for sharing this really important
information
and for pit masters at home who want to
apply for the preserve the pit
fellowship you have until march 1st
and we'll share the details on our
website at the drewberrymore show.com
thank you so much thank you very much
thank you for your time thank you
great to meet you
and see you soon what are you saying we
want to leave you with something that
you can take on the road with you it's
time for doggy bag
well it's the perfect accompaniment to
not only meat week any food situation
this is my go-to it's seluna
is the brand it's kimberly snyder who is
a true
guru on health and wellness and
digestion
and this is the feel good digestive
enzymes and you take them right before a
meal and they help your body metabolize
proteins fats and carbs more effectively
i never go anywhere without it it is my
amex card
and i notice a huge difference in my
weight gain
if i don't take it for reals or reals
i'll take two
yeah there you go i take three before
every meal well thank you for these i'm
obsessed and thank you all for watching
we hope you could see you again
we hope you have a wonderful day thank
you
[Music]
you